Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory. tour of uh the world's 32 most successful footballing nations today dominic we are arriving in poland we are and tour is the right word tom because we will be doing something of a tour in this um episode because i thought we should do something completely different which we haven't done before. So you know the seven wonders of the
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及我们备受喜爱的聊天社区会员资格，请访问 therestishistory. 巡礼——我们今天的目的地是世界上足球成绩最辉煌的 32 个国家之一。多米尼克，我们正抵达波兰。是的，而且用“巡礼”这个词再准确不过了，汤姆，因为我们在这个……这期节目里确实要做一次巡礼，因为我想我们可以做一些完全不同、以前没做过的事情。所以，你知道古代的七大
ancient world? I do, yeah. Can you name all seven? Well it's complicated because they vary. They do. So the commonly acknowledged ones are the Statue of Zeus at Olympia the Hangar of Babylon and sometimes the Walls of Babylon. Yes.
奇观吗？我知道，对。你能说出全部七个吗？嗯，这有点复杂，因为它们的说法不一。确实如此。所以普遍公认的有：奥林匹亚的宙斯神像、巴比伦的空中花园，有时还有巴比伦城墙。是的。
And sometimes the walls of Babylon. Oh, I don't have them on my list. So sometimes they're included. The Mausoleum in Halicarnassus, the Pharos in Alexandria. Yes, yes, the lighthouse, exactly. The Great Pyramid, which is the only surviving one. How many have I done so far? I can't remember.
有时还有巴比伦城墙。哦，我的名单上没有这个。所以有时候它们会被包括在内。哈利卡纳索斯的摩索拉斯王陵墓，亚历山大的法罗斯灯塔。对，对，灯塔，没错。吉萨大金字塔，这是唯一幸存的一座。我刚才说了几个了？我记不清了。
You've done six. I think you've got one to go. Oh, no, you've got two to go only you've got two to go do you want to put your misery the colossus of roads colossus roads yes and what was the temple of artemis oh yes at ephesus at ephesus yeah so they were supposedly that comes from somebody called antipater of sidon in the second century we've got to do an episode on them we yeah it'd be a brilliant episode yeah it's it's a real the whole backstory to it's so interesting but far distant from poland it is far distant from poland but of course ever since people have you know people have said what are the seven wonders of the modern world what are the seven wonders of britain all this sort of stuff and in the year 2007 the polish newspaper resh poshpolita named as you will know Tom from Reszpublika
你说了六个。我想你还有一个没说。哦，不对，你还有两个没说，只有两个没说。你想痛快点吗？罗德岛巨像。罗德岛巨像，对。还有什么？阿尔忒弥斯神庙。哦，对，在以弗所。在以弗所，对。所以这些据说……这源于公元前二世纪一个叫西顿的安提帕特的人。我们得做一期关于它们的节目。我们……那会是一期非常精彩的节目。对，这真的很……整个背景故事太有趣了，但离波兰太远了。离波兰确实很远，但当然，从那以后，人们一直……你知道，人们会说什么是现代世界七大奇观，什么是英国七大奇观，诸如此类的话。而在 2007 年，波兰报纸《共和国报》（Rzeczpospolita）评选出了——正如你所知，汤姆，从“Reszpospolita”这个词——
yes the Latin for Republic right exactly and named after the official name of the Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth
是的，就是拉丁语的“共和国”，对吧？完全正确。而且它得名于波兰立陶宛联邦的官方名称——
a subject that we've often talked about doing on the rest of history and still haven't done but we will and we haven't done so the Polish newspaper
这是一个我们经常说要在《历史的余烬》里聊聊、但至今还没聊过的主题，不过我们以后会聊的，而我们还没聊过，所以波兰报纸——
Reszposzpolita which is I guess Poland's kind of newspaper record so it's a bit like le monde or the or the daily mail exactly not the daily house and uh they had they had a competition and uh they had hundreds of entries and experts whittled them down and the public voted and i thought it would be fun to talk about the seven wonders of poland as voted for by the polls and what they tell us about history so we shall just crack on start with number seven okay dominic before we do this i
《Rzeczpospolita》，我想这就相当于波兰的官方核心报纸，所以有点像法国的《世界报》或者英国的《每日邮报》——完全不是《每日邮报》。他们当时举办了一场比赛，收到了几百份投稿，专家们将候选名单筛选下来，然后由公众投票。我想，聊聊由波兰人投票选出的波兰七大奇观，以及它们向我们透露了哪些历史，应该会很有趣。所以我们这就开始吧，从第七名开始。好的，多米尼克，在此之前，我——
have to put my hands up and say i have never been to poland oh but it is very high on my list of places to visit so i suspecting that this will absolutely confirm me in that it definitely will because i think this this this podcast is not sponsored by the Polish Tourist Board. It absolutely should be. But if they're listening, and they'd like to make a contribution. They should make a contribution. We wouldn't say no, would we? We wouldn't say no.
必须坦白一件事，那就是我从来没去过波兰。哦！但它在我的必去清单上名列前茅。所以我猜这绝对会让我坚定这个想法。绝对会，因为我觉得——这个播客并不是由波兰旅游局赞助的。它绝对应该赞助。但如果他们在听，而且想赞助点什么的话……他们应该赞助。我们不会拒绝，对吧？我们当然不会拒绝。
So we'll start off in, I suppose, the city that most people naturally gravitate to in Poland, which is not Warsaw, the capital, it's the city of krakow so krakow beautiful city not unlike prague um in its in its appearance like all great cities it has a legend so krakow was established on in a place called weibel hill and the story goes that it had a mythical ruler called krakus who who built the city above a cave that was occupied by a dragon called Smok Vavelski. Lots of knights tried to kill this dragon and failed, but Cracus, who's culling and he was also culinary-minded,
所以我们要从……我想，大多数人自然而然会想到的波兰城市开始。这个城市不是首都华沙，而是克拉科夫。所以，克拉科夫是一座美丽的城市，在外貌上有点像布拉格。像所有伟大的城市一样，它也有一个传说。所以克拉科夫建立在一个叫做瓦维尔山的地方，故事说，这里有一个神话中的统治者叫克拉克（Krakus），他在一个被一条叫斯莫克·瓦韦尔斯基（Smok Wawelski）的巨龙占领的洞穴上方建造了这座城市。许多骑士试图杀死这条龙，但都失败了。不过克拉克——他不仅喜欢屠龙，还很有烹饪头脑——
he poisoned a lamb and gave it to the dragon, and the dragon ate it and died. So that was great news for him and for the Poles generally. I think that's slightly cheating. Well, i mean oh it did work but but i mean it's it's an oddly unheroic way to kill a dragon what i'm going to say to you is like getting rid of a rat or something krakus has a wonder of poland named after him and you do not well yeah but i don't think i have to i don't think i have to have killed a dragon to to criticize someone for their lack of dragon kid dragon killing i think you do i think if you haven't no that's ridiculous i think if you haven't walked the walk as as
他在一只羊身上下了毒，然后把羊喂给了巨龙，巨龙吃了之后就死掉了。这对克拉克和波兰人民来说都是个好消息。我觉得这有点作弊。嗯，我是说……哦，这确实管用，但这是一种奇怪的、毫无英雄气概的杀死巨龙的方法。我想对你说的是，这就像消灭一只老鼠什么的。克拉科夫有一个以他的名字命名的波兰奇观，而你却没有。好吧，是的，但我不认为我必须……我不认为我必须杀了一条龙，才有资格批评别人缺乏屠龙能力。我觉得你必须这样。我觉得如果你没有像屠龙者那样——
dragon slayers say dominic that's like saying unless you've been a premier football manager you can't criticize them well that's what premier league football yeah i know they do say well anyway listen whatever that's what dragon sl football yeah i know they do say well anyway listen whatever that's what dragon slayer say let's get back to krakow so it's around
多米尼克，这就好像在说，除非你当过顶级足球教练，否则你不能批评他们。好吧，这就是英超联赛足球……我知道人们确实这么说。好吧，不管怎样，听着，管它呢……这就是屠龙……足球……我知道人们确实这么说。好吧，不管怎样，听着，管它呢……这就是屠龙者……让我们回到克拉科夫。所以在……
krakow in what's the area known as wilko polska that the the tribe of the polands so the poles um set up this sort of predecessor of the
克拉科夫周边，也就是被称为大波兰（Wielkopolska）的地区，波兰人的部落……也就是波兰人，在公元 10 世纪左右建立了波兰国家的这种前身。正是 在 10 世纪，我们有了第一个名字，即来自一位塞法迪犹太旅行者的“克拉科夫”这个名字的出现。在 10 世纪，可能是在 11 世纪，它成为了波兰政府的所在地。
polish state in about the 10th century uh it's in the 10th century that we have the first name, the appearance of the name Krakow, from a Sephardic Jewish traveler. The 10th, probably the 11th century, it becomes the seat of the Polish government.
它差点被蒙古人摧毁。但随后它成为了汉萨同盟的成员——克拉科夫就是这样——所以它有行会，有图书馆，还有联排别墅、精巧的房屋，完全是这样。是的。问题是，在西方，这么多年来，我们这一代人成长过程中内化了铁幕的概念，认为东西欧之间存在着这种固定、僵化的分界线。而对波兰的研究以及这七大奇观的故事，完全颠覆了这一切。因为如果不认识到波兰在多大程度上融入了低地国家、斯堪的纳维亚、德国等地区的世界，你就根本无法理解这一切。
It's almost destroyed by the Mongols. But then it becomes a member of the Hanseatic league um krakow so it has guilds and it has libraries and townhouses thin houses exactly yeah and the thing is in the west for so many years people of our generation we grew up having internalized the iron curtain and thinking of this kind of this this fixed division between eastern and western europe and the study of of Poland and this story of the Seven Wonders of Poland completely turns all that on its head because it's impossible to make any sense unless you realize how much Poland was integrated in that world of the Low Countries, Scandinavia, Germany,
你在克拉科夫市中心那个宏伟的、极好的公共空间——中央集市广场（Rynek Główny）中就能看到这一点。那是中央集市广场，对吧？就是克拉科夫的主广场。它是欧洲最大的中世纪广场。它被称为 Rinek Gwovni。它是在蒙古入侵后建造的。所以我们说的是大约 14 世纪。
and so on and so forth. And you see that in this great, this fantastic public space in the center of Krakow, which is the Wander. That is the Wander, is it? Which is the main square of Krakow. It's the largest medieval square in Europe. It's called the Rinek Gwovni. It was built after the Mongol invasion. So we're talking about sort of 14th century.
广场周围的大多数建筑现在都比较新了，你知道的，它们已经被 17 世纪和 18 世纪的建筑所取代，但其中有两座建筑特别值得一提。一座是市政厅钟楼，这是一座美妙的哥特式建筑，它是中世纪市政厅唯一留存的部分。它是用砖建造的——波兰的许多建筑都是用砖建造的，所以它是一种哥特式红砖建筑，这很不寻常。你知道的，你在低地国家能看到这种建筑，在丹麦或其他地方也可能看到，但你在西班牙或意大利等地显然看不到。关于克拉科夫的一件事是……是的，我想这个伟大的广场是……关于克拉科夫的一件事，我想这个伟大的广场是……波兰少数几个未在第二次世界大战中被摧毁的文化中心之一。
Most of the buildings surrounding the the square are newer by now you know they've been replaced by 17th and 18th century buildings but there are two buildings in particular that are that are worthy of note so one is the the tower of the town hall a fantastic gothic building it's the only bit of the medieval town hall that's left it's made of so many of the buildings are in poland that made a brick so it's kind of gothic brick which is unusual you know you you see that in the low countries you might see that in denmark or somewhere but you don't really see it you know you obviously don't see it in spain or italy or whatever and and one of the things about krakow yeah and i guess this this great square is that it's it's one of the things about Krakow, and I guess this great square, is that it's one of the few cultural centres in Poland
是这样吗？是的。嗯，事实上，我们稍后会在这个名单上讲到其他几个。不过你说得对，为了奇观的幸存。古代世界七大奇观只有一个幸存，其余的都消失了。
that is not devastated in the Second World War. Is that right? Yes. Well, we'll come to a couple of others, actually, later in this list. But you're right. For the survival of wonders. So only one survivor of the seven wonders of the ancient world, they're all gone.
但波兰在二战中遭受了如此惨重的苦难，以至于这些建筑的存在本身就是一个奇观。本身就是一个奇观。完全同意，完全同意。所以，市政厅钟楼，但实际上更令人印象深刻的是布匹会馆（Cloth Hall）。我太喜欢布匹会馆了。你很喜欢布匹会馆。
But Poland suffered so grievously in the Second World War that the very existence of these is a wonder in itself. Is a wonder in itself. Agreed, completely agreed. So the Town Hall Tower, but even more impressive, actually, is the Cloth Hall. I love a Cloth Hall. You love a Cloth Hall.
没有什么比布匹会馆更能代表汉萨同盟了。完全正确，正中要害。所以，布匹会馆，对于那些不太了解的人来说——克拉科夫当时的位置是进行贸易的绝佳地点，因为人们可以从基辅罗斯前来，可以从立陶宛和波罗的海地区前来，可以从匈牙利和德国前来，可以从北海进入波罗的海，然后顺流而下等等。他们在这个集市广场上出售他们的商品。布匹会馆是其中的一个巨大组成部分。
Nothing is more Hanseatic League than a Cloth Hall. Exactly, exactly the point. So the Cloth Hall, for those of you who don't know, so Krakow was situated, it was a perfect place for trade because people could come from Kiev and Rus', they could come from Lithuania and the Baltic, they could come from Hungary and Germany, they could come from the North Sea into the Baltic and then down the rivers and so on. And they would sell their wares in this market square. And the cloth hall was a huge part of that.
它原本是一座中世纪建筑，后来在文艺复兴时期进行了改建。所以说到文艺复兴，没人会想到波兰，至少英国没人会这么想。哥白尼，我想算一个。嗯，哥白尼可能会出场，汤姆。哦，太令人兴奋了。我知道你有点科学情结。我的确有。尤其是有点科学情结。我的确有。尤其是文艺复兴时期的科学。
And it's originally a medieval building, but then it was remodeled in Renaissance fashion. So nobody thinks of Poland when it comes to the Renaissance, at least nobody in Britain. Copernicus, I suppose. Well, Copernicus may feature, Tom. Oh, very exciting. I know you like a bit of science. I do. Especially a bit of science. I do. Especially a bit of Renaissance science.
所以布匹会馆现在是一座壮观的红白相间的文艺复兴风格建筑。它有柱廊，现在被用作美术馆。从它以及广场延伸出去，是一片文艺复兴和巴洛克时期的街道网格。所以汤姆，实际上你会很喜欢它。你绝对应该去克拉科夫。我得去，是的。
So the Cloth Hall is now the spectacular red and white Renaissance building. It's colonnaded. It's used as an art gallery. And out from it and from the square, there's this kind of grid of Renaissance and kind of Baroque era streets. So Tom, actually, you would love it. You should definitely go to Krakow. I've got to go yeah
是的。现在，克拉科夫从……我的意思是，也许你可以认为它保存得这么好的一个原因——他实际上有点在 16 世纪末（1596 年）失去了显赫地位——就像布鲁日或根特一样，完全是这样。因此，新国王西吉斯蒙德三世·瓦萨（Sigismund III Vasa）——他是波兰国王——这简直难以置信，他曾是波兰、立陶宛、瑞典和芬兰的国王。这对于一个我猜我们大多数听众可能都没听说过的人来说，实在太令人印象深刻了——他将首都迁到了华沙。这更有意义，因为这样首都位于他那辽阔王国的更中心位置。在他那辽阔的王国里，完全正确。关于克拉科夫的另一个有趣之处当然是它有很浓厚的犹太特色。所以在二战前，它大约有 90 座犹太会堂，
yeah now crockoff fell from i mean perhaps you could argue one reason it's so well preserved he says actually slightly fell from prominence at the end of the 16th century in 1596 yeah so kind of like bruges or ghent or exactly so a new king sigismund vasa he was king of poland i mean incredible he was king of poland lithuania sweden and finland very impressive for a man who most of our listeners i'm guessing will probably not have heard of and he relocates the capital to warsaw makes much more sense uh because it's going to be it's more central within his vast kingdom with his vast kingdom exactly and the other interesting thing about crock of course is very jewish so before World War II, it had about 90 synagogues
多达三分之一的人口是犹太人。当然，绝大多数犹太人后来都被纳粹和大屠杀摧毁了。辛德勒就是从这里为他的工厂招募人员的。没错，《辛德勒的名单》的故事就发生在这里，完全没错。波兰斯基当时就在那里的犹太人隔离区里，罗曼·波兰斯基。你知道吗？波兰斯基也会回归的。
and maybe as much as a third of its population was Jewish. And of course, the overwhelming majority of them were destroyed by the Nazis and the Holocaust. That's where Schindler recruited people from his factories. Right, Schindler's List is set, exactly. Polanski was in the ghetto there, Roman Polanski. And do you know what? Polanski will also be returning.
罗曼·波兰斯基和他的家人也会回归。我有点操之过急了。不，不，你能铺垫各种我们可以在故事中继续追踪的线索，这太棒了。所以克拉科夫中央集市广场是我们的第一个奇观。现在，你刚才谈到了那些完美保存、在二战中未被摧毁的地方，这份名单上的第二名也是如此。
Roman Polanski and his family will also be returning. I'm jumping the gun. No, no, it's great that you're setting up all kinds of threads that we should follow through the story. So the Krakow Main Square is our first wonder. Now, you were talking about places that were perfectly preserved and not destroyed in the Second World War, and that is true of number two on the list.
所以第二名是一个叫扎莫希奇（Zamość）的小镇。汤姆，你听说过扎莫希奇吗？没有，我没听说过。它位于波兰极东地区，非常靠近乌克兰边境。它是保存完好的、规划有序的文艺复兴时期小镇的独一无二的典范。所以，又是这种文艺复兴的特色。
So number two is a town called Zamość. So have you ever heard of Zamość, Tom? No, I haven't. So it's in the far east of Poland. So it's very close to the Ukrainian border. It is a unique example of a perfectly preserved, planned Renaissance town. So again, this Renaissance quality.
这是另一个极好的例子，说明东西欧之间存在区别这种想法是毫无意义的。因为它基本上就是波兰极东地区的一座意大利风格小镇。那么它为什么会出现在那里呢？现在我们必须从这段中世纪时期再往前跨越一点时间。所以在 16 世纪，波兰是波兰立陶宛联邦的一部分，这是欧洲最大的国家，这个庞大的庞然大物拥有极其巨大的多样性——宗教、文化、民族的多样性。它们维系在一起的东西之一，就是自称为“什拉赫塔”（Szlachta）的政治精英阶层。所以他们相当于贵族阶层。
It's another brilliant example of how the idea of a distinction between Western and Eastern Europe is meaningless. Because it's basically an Italianate town in the far east of uh poland so so what's it doing there well now we have to sort of leap a bit further forward in time from the sort of medieval period so in the 16th century poland was part of the polish lithuanian commonwealth the biggest state in europe this absolutely sort of sprawling beast with colossal diversity religious cultural ethnic diversity one of the things they held together was the political elite, who called themselves the Slashta. So they were the kind of nobility.
按 16 世纪的标准来看，他们有两件非常奇怪的事情。第一件是他们痴迷于一种叫做“萨尔马提亚主义”（Sarmatianism）的东西。所以他们相信自己是萨尔马提亚人的后代——萨尔马提亚人是斯拉夫人的伊朗草原主人。是的。他们真的是吗？我想他们不是。不，但他们的装扮就像萨尔马提亚人。他们穿著角色扮演性质的东方风情服装，戴着头巾，佩戴镶宝石的短剑，诸如此类。多有趣啊。
And they had two very strange things about them by the standards of the 16th century. The first was they were devotees of something called Sarmatianism. So they believed they were descended from the psalmations the iranian steppe masters of the slavs yes and were they i guess they weren't no but they dressed as psalmations so they wore cosplay orientalist clothing they had they sort of put on turbans they wore jewel dag daggers, all this kind of thing. What fun.
所以，如果你去了波兰，在文艺复兴时期去见那些贵族……你会以为自己身处萨尔马提亚。是的。或者甚至，你会觉得自己置身于某种印第安纳·琼斯或詹姆斯·邦德电影中最糟糕的东方主义场景中，
So if you'd gone to Poland and gone to meet the nobility in the era of the Renaissance... You'd think you were in Sarmatia. Yeah. Or indeed, you'd think you were in some sort of Indiana Jones or James Bond film of the worst orientalizing kind
人们带着弯刀之类的东西，留着夸张的胡子，但显然只是在精心打扮一番。是的。所以情况就是这样，而另一件事是他们痴迷的东西——这与你很像，汤姆——那就是古代罗马。所以除了做所有这些之外，他们还把头发剪成古罗马风格。这有点……有点难。当你身上挂着一把镶宝石的弯刀时，还要弄这个发型就很难了，但他们偏要这么做。好吧，我可以理解穿得像个罗马人。我可以理解穿得像个……你知道的，草原蛮族。
with people with scimitars and stuff and colossal mustaches but who were clearly just dressing up yeah um so there's that and the other thing they're obsessed with not unlike you tom is ancient rome so as well as doing all this they also have their hair cut like ancient rome now that's slightly it's a bit of a yeah it's difficult to do that when you're carrying off a jeweled scimitar, but they do it. Okay, so I can understand dressing like a Roman. I can understand dressing like a, you know, a barbarian of the steppes.
是的。但同时做这两件事……为什么不同时做呢？为什么不同时做呢？好吧，我想，是的，这太不可思议了。我的意思是，如果你是一个波兰贵族，你确实可以。你有钱。我想这是真的。文艺复兴显然解释了为什么他们对古罗马这么感兴趣。
Yeah. To do both. Why not do both? Why not do both? Well, I suppose, yeah, it's incredible. I mean, if you're a Polish nobleman, you can. You have the money. I suppose that's true. The Renaissance obviously explains why they're so interested in ancient Rome.
是的，因为那是标准。我的意思是，他们在整个欧洲历史中都在模仿罗马。但萨尔马提亚人，我认为这是因为他们的地理位置。这大概是因为他们的地理位置，可以说是位于伟大的欧亚草原的边缘，对吧？你难道不这么认为吗？我的意思是，其中有一些元素是因为他们认为自己——当然，如果他们统治着波兰立陶宛联邦，他们的领土就涵盖了现代的白俄罗斯、西乌克兰等等，事实上大部分乌克兰都在其中。所以他们离草原游牧民族并不是那么遥远，他们希望将自己视作这种……
Yeah, because that's the standard. I mean are aping rome throughout european history but the psalmations i think it's their location it's their location probably you could argue at the end of the great eurasian step yes would you not say i mean that there's some elements of that that they see themselves because of course their territory if they're ruling the polish lithuanian commonwealth their territory covers modern-day Belarus, Western Ukraine, and so on, much of Ukraine, in fact. So they're not that far away from step-nomads, and they want to see themselves as the kind of...
兼具两者。是的，完全正确。两个世界的桥梁，多米尼克。非常好。波兰，对比鲜明之国。如果波兰旅游局想联系我们的话，正如我所说，是的，请不要犹豫。所以他们……如果你是一个受过良好教育的年轻男子，你总是会去意大利旅行，你会去威尼斯，或者特别是去帕多瓦。帕多瓦是 16 世纪波兰年轻人极其热门的目的地。
As both. Yes, exactly. A bridge between two worlds, Dominic. Very nice. Poland, land of contrasts. And if the Polish tourist board want to get in touch as i say yeah don't don't hesitate so they um so they will always if you have if you're an educated young man you will travel to italy you'll go to venice or particularly to padua padua is a hugely popular destination for young Poles in the 16th century.
有什么特殊原因吗？我觉得这是那种经典的“临界点”效应。是的。很多人去了，然后更多的人也跟着去。所以在 16 世纪中后期，有一个惊人的统计数据：帕多瓦大学四分之一的学生都是波兰人。哇。他们回到家乡，建造了意大利文艺复兴风格的宫殿、
Is there any particular reason for that? I think it's that classic thing of a kind of critical mass. Yeah. Lots go and then more do go. So in the mid to late 16th century, an astonishing statistic, one in four students at the University of Padua is Polish. Wow. And they come back home and they build Italian Renaissance palaces
教堂、乡村宅邸等等。但有一个叫扬·扎莫伊斯基（Jan Zamoyski）的人，他做到了极致。所以他就是那种典型的波兰参议员之子，生于 1542 年。他去过巴黎大学，去过斯特拉斯堡大学，当然也去过帕多瓦大学，并在 1564 年在那里获得了法学博士学位。汤姆，他写了一本小册子——这非常符合你的风格——他写了一本名为《论罗马元老院》（De Senatu Romanu）的小册子，
and churches and country houses and things. But there's a guy called Jan Zamoyski, and he goes one better. So he is your classic kind of senator's son from Poland, born in 1542. He's gone to the Sorbonne. He's gone to the University of Strasbourg. He's gone, of course, to Padua, where he gets a law doctorate in 1564. He writes, Tom, very much a man after your heart, he writes a brochure, a little brochure called De Senatu Romanu,
讲述了古罗马政府及其运作方式。他回到家乡，成为了波兰立陶宛联邦的大元帅兼首相（Chancellor）。他获得了高级职务的所有标志。他决定，其他人虽然都建造了教堂之类的建筑，但我要做得更好。我要建造一整座城市。我要建造理想的柏拉图式城市。
about ancient Roman government and how it worked. He comes back home. He becomes Chancellor of the Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth. He has all signs of senior offices. And he decides, all these other people have built churches and stuff. I'm going to go much better than that. I'm going to build a whole city. I'm going to build the ideal platonic city.
这就是扎莫希奇。所以他想以他在意大利见过的城市为蓝本。他找了一个名叫贝尔纳多·莫兰多（Bernardo Morando）的建筑师。你想不想猜猜他想以他在意大利见过的城市为蓝本……他找了一个名叫贝尔纳多·莫兰多的建筑师。你想不想猜猜他是哪里人？呃，他是意大利人吗？对，帕多瓦镇人，他来自帕多瓦，完全正确。所以这就是……这是查尔斯王子的……是的，这有点像英国的庞伯里镇（Poundbury）。这就是庞伯里。所以贝尔纳多·莫兰多建造并设计了这座城市。这座城市完全是几何形的，一切都是垂直的，街道是平行的。你在一端有一座宫殿，市中心有一座市政厅，周围环绕着星形堡垒，还有带拱廊的两层公寓楼，也就是有柱廊和各种明亮色彩的建筑。这是一个巨大的成功。对于《历史的余烬》来说，难得有一回事情没有出岔子。他建造了这个地方，它绝对美丽。同样——我之前在克拉科夫时提过这一点——扎莫希奇后来成为了一个非常重要的犹太人中心，
And that's Zamość. So he wants to model it on the cities that he's seen in Italy. He gets an architect called Bernardo Morando. Do you want the cities that he's seen in italy he gets a an architect called bernardo mirando do you want to guess where he's from uh would he be from italy yeah the town padua he's from padua exactly so this is the this is the prince charles of yes it's kind of the poundberry of it is the poundberry so bernardoardo Miranda builds this, designs this city, which is all geometric, everything perpendicular, the streets parallel. You've got a palace at one end, you've got the town hall at the center, a star-shaped fort surrounding it, arcaded kind of two-story tenement houses, so colonnades and things all brightly colored and and it's a tremendous i mean it's a great success you know for once in the rest is history nothing goes wrong he builds this place it's absolutely beautiful again um i mentioned this with klakoff zamost becomes a very
因此它成了哈西迪派犹太教（Hasidic Judaism）的一个伟大基地。到二战爆发时，住在这个文艺复兴意大利风格小镇上的人口中，有将近一半是犹太人。他们都在最可怕的情况下被德国人驱逐了。我的意思是，阅读关于从扎莫希奇驱逐的那些故事简直令人毛骨悚然。许多人在当场被杀。其余的人基本上都在贝乌热茨（Belzec）或奥斯威辛被杀害。
big jewish center so it becomes a great base for hasidic Judaism. So the outbreak of World War II, just under half of its population who are living in these, this sort of Renaissance Italian style town are Jews. They are all deported by the Germans under the most horrific circumstances. I mean, to read the stories of the deportation from Zamość are horrible. Many of them were killed on the spot. The rest basically were all killed in Belzec or Auschwitz.
所以为了让你对死亡人数有个概念，战前那里大约有近 13,000 人。到战争结束时，只剩下 7 个人。所以，你知道，这太可怕了。德国人到那里的时候，对这个地方并不感冒。事实证明，他们并不……我还以为他们会挺喜欢这种文艺复兴风格的建筑呢。他们说这里不够具有
So to give you a sense of the death toll, there were about almost 13,000 before the war. By the end of the war, there were seven. So, you know, awful. The Germans, when they got there, were not impressed with the place. They did not, it turned out. I thought they would enjoy a bit of of they said it wasn't in a sufficiently
德意志特色，对吧？他们不喜欢东波兰出现意大利文艺复兴风格的建筑。党卫军接管了这里，他们想把它改名为“希姆莱城”（Himmlerstadt）。但希姆莱拒绝了，因为希特勒当时还没有以自己的名字命名城市，这样做会显得僭越、自大。所以他们决定将其改名为“普卢格施塔特”（Pflugstadt），意思是“犁城”，这个名字可没有扎莫希奇那么好听。他们想炸掉所有的建筑，用德国建筑取而代之。但幸运的是——这又是一个主题，我们待会儿还会提到——
german right they didn't like a sort of italian renaissance building in eastern poland the ss took it over and they wanted to call it to rename it himmler start and himmler said no because hitler had not yet had a city named after him and it would be presumptuous presumptuous so they decided they would rename it flugstart which means plow town which is not as good a name as zosch and they wanted to blow up all the buildings and replace them with german buildings but fortunately well and this is a theme well again we'll come back to the local german administrator thought this was bonkers you know he just thought that was crazy so he played for time he kept saying well what kind of german architecture
当地的德国行政长官认为这简直是疯了。他觉得这太疯狂了，所以他在拖延时间。他一直说：“嗯，我们要用什么样的德国建筑来取代它呢？”并且拒绝所有的设计方案，以此确保基本上在红军抵达解放它之前，他们还没来得及把它炸毁。这就是为什么如果你今天去波兰东部的扎莫希奇，它仍然是文艺复兴时期价值观的完美保存的殿堂。我可以问一下吗，建造它的扎莫伊斯基伯爵，是亚当·扎莫伊斯基（Adam Zamoyski）的祖先吗？我想是的。这位杰出的波兰历史学家。
would we replace it with and rejecting all the designs to make sure that basically they hadn't blown it up by the time the red army arrived to liberate it and that's why if you go to some today in the east of poland it is still this perfectly preserved temple to the values of the Renaissance. And can I ask you, the Count Zamoyski who built it, is he the ancestor of Adam Zamoyski? I believe he is. The distinguished Polish historian.
完全正确。我想是的。我知道亚当·扎莫伊斯基是伟大的扎莫伊斯基王朝的一部分。所以，即使他无法追溯自己的直系血统，也几乎肯定有某种联系。好吧，这是另一个必去的地方。好的。那么汤姆，那是第七个、第六个，现在是第五个。这个地方的最大问题在于你是否喜欢运河。
Exactly. I believe he is. I know that Adam Zamoyski is part of the great Zamoyski dynasty. So even if he can't trace his descent, I think there's almost definitely a link. Okay, so that's another place to visit. Yes, good. So Tom, that was number seven, number six, now number five. The big question with this one is whether or not you like canals.
我太喜欢运河了。我刚从威尼斯回来。哦，天哪。上个月我才去过威尼斯。我还坐了贡多拉。好吧。我喜欢运河。但这是一种非常不同的运河。
I love a canal. I've just come back from Venice. Oh, my word. Last month I was in Venice. I went on a gondola. Okay. I love a canal. It's a very different kind of canal.
你知道的，我喜欢伯明翰——北方的威尼斯。嗯，这是一条乡村运河。你对乡村运河感兴趣吗？是的，我很感兴趣。这就是埃尔布隆格运河（Elbląg Canal）。它的拼写是 Elblag，但发音是 elbląg，我的波兰联系人是这么告诉我……所以我们在这里时间跨度跳跃得更远了。扎莫伊斯基家族建造扎莫希奇的时期，可以说是波兰的真正黄金时代，
You know, and I love Birmingham, the Venice of the north. Well, this is a rural canal. Are you happy with rural canals? Yes, I'm happy. So this is the Elblong Canal. It's spelt Elblag but it's pronounced elbląg so my uh polish contacts tell me um and so we've leaped further forward in time here so the zamoyski kind of period when they're building zamoysk is kind of a real golden age for
波兰充满自信等等。但从 17 世纪中叶开始，波兰开始走向衰落。它遭到瑞典的入侵，遭到俄罗斯的入侵。华沙被瑞典人摧毁。波兰人将这段时期称为“大洪水”（The Deluge）时期。我认为历史上有个时期叫“大洪水”可真不是什么好事。
the poles um you know poland is big in self-confidence and so on. But from the mid-17th century onwards, Poland is in decline. It's invaded by Sweden. It's invaded by Russia. Warsaw is destroyed by the Swedes. This is the period that the Poles call the Deluge. And I think it's never good to have a period in your history called the Deluge.
有点像我们一直在经历的时代。他们最终被邻国瓜分，也就是俄罗斯、普鲁士和奥地利。在 18 世纪末，一部分被普鲁士占领。现在，埃尔布隆格（Elbląg）地区最初是由条顿骑士团建立的，后来被波兰接管。然后到了 18 世纪末，它成为了普鲁士的一部分，
Slightly what we've been living through. They end up being partitioned by their neighbours, so Russia, Prussia and Austria. And in the late 18th century, a bit is taken over by Prussia. Now, the area of Elbląg had been founded by the Teutonic Knights and it had been then taken over by Poland. And then at the end of the 18th century, it becomes Prussian,
基本上成了东普鲁士。如果你注定要被俄罗斯人、普鲁士人和奥地利人瓜分，我想——听起来可能有点奇怪——你大概还是希望自己被划进普鲁士那一块。因为他们会为你建设工业基础设施。完全正确。普鲁士人是
becomes basically East Prussia. If you are going to be partitioned by the Russians, the Prussians and the Austrians, I guess, I mean, it seems like a weird thing to say, but you probably want to be in the Prussian bit. Because they'll build you industrial infrastructure. Exactly. The Prussians are the
经济最发达的。当然，没有哪个是理想的。我觉得你最不想被划进俄国那一块，坦白说。难道不是历来如此吗？历来如此。但普鲁士人投资于经济发展。所以埃尔布隆格运河就是这方面最著名的例子。它建于 1825 年至 1844 年之间，长达 50 英里。我们生活在一个以运河、工业运河闻名的国家。所以你可能会想：那又怎样？谁在乎呢？但它神奇的地方在于，它连接了处于完全不同水平面上的陆地。
most economically advanced. I mean, none of it's ideal. I think you least want to be in the Russian bit, frankly. Isn't that always the case? It is always the case. But the Prussians invest in economic development. So the Elbląg Canal is the most famous example of this. It's built between 1825 and 1844. It's 50 miles long. Now, we live in a country famous for its canals, its industrial canals. So you might think, well, so what? Who cares? The amazing thing about it is that it connects land areas that are on completely different levels.
因此，你不需要经历那种……你知道的，运河走到尽头什么的。他们所做的是，你的船会开上轨道上的一种拖车，然后利用各种滑轮和机械装置，基本上把你拉上这个陡峭的……哦，对，有点像主题公园里的游乐设施！完全就像主题公园里的游乐设施，然后你呼啸着冲下去，溅起水花！完全正确。所以基本上就是这样。这比必须通过大量的船闸要省力得多，不是吗？
And instead of you having to sort of you know the canal comes to an end or something what they do is your boat goes on to a kind of carriage on a track and it uses all kind of wheels and stuff to basically pull you up this steep oh right so a bit like um those rides at theme parks right exactly like the rides at theme parks and then you go whooshing down and get splashed exactly so basically does that so that's that's i mean that's a lot less work than having to go up loads of locks isn't it exactly it's much it's much it's it's much better than locks actually i think it would be much i haven't been on it myself michael palin has been on it has he he went to his in his series
完全正确。这比船闸好得多，好得多。实际上，我觉得这会非常……我还没亲自坐过。迈克尔·帕林（Michael Palin）坐过。是吗？他在他的纪录片系列《新欧洲》（New Europe）中去过那里，在他的书中有一大段描述：他们正以完全正常的状态航行，然后突然发现自己开始以大约 45 度角向上行驶！哦，我可不坐这个。是的，让我们看看……他们与另一艘正以 45 度角从他们旁边滑下去的船擦身而过，这听起来太神奇了！所以你在旅途中要做很多这种斜坡滑道。所以这是波兰曾经属于普鲁士的一部分，后来被接管……这是欧洲唯一有这种运河的地方吗？这就是它成为奇观的原因，还是这只是标准的普鲁士运河建造技术？我对运河技术不是很熟悉。
the new europe and he's got a big description in his book about how they're sailing along perfectly normally and then they suddenly they find themselves going up at kind of 45 degrees oh i'm not gonna do it yeah let's see they pass another boat that's going down at 45 degrees next to them which sounds absolutely amazing so they go you do lots of these sort of slipways in your journey so this is a part of poland that was prussian and then it was taken over uh and is this is this the only place in europe where they have this is that why it's a wonder or is this standard prussian canal building. I'm not massively familiar with canal technology. Right.
不过我想我从来没听说过哪个地方有这种运河。我从没听说过。不，这听起来太棒了。所以，汤姆，你也会喜欢这个的。我会的，听起来……是的。
But I think I've never heard of anywhere having it. I've never heard of it. No. It sounds great. So, Tom, you would like that as well. I would. It sounds. Yes.
你知道吗？我很想策划一次完全围绕这七大奇观展开的波兰之旅。波兰有一个地方我特别想去，我很好奇它是否在名单上。如果不在的话，那我就有八大奇观了。我想我们现在应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将揭晓最后四大奇观，看看我想去参观的那个奇观
Do you know what? I'm quite minded to work out a trip to Poland that's entirely structured around these seven wonders. And there's one place in Poland I particularly want to visit and I will be interested to see if it's in the list. And if it's not, then I'll have eight wonders. I think at this point, we should take a break. And when we come back, we'll have the last four wonders and we'll see if the wonder that I want to visit
是否在其中。非常棒。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。……是否在其中。非常棒。获取免费收听、加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。这是我们在世界杯漫游之旅中的波兰期节目，我们正在探讨波兰七大奇观。我们已经讲了三个，多米尼克，现在你要给我们讲第四个了。所以，汤姆，你会记得你之前非常怀疑——我觉得你对那个用羊毒死恶龙的克拉克持有一种近乎残酷的怀疑。
is numbered among them. Very good. I'm Marina Hyde. among them. Very good. free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to the rest is history our polish episode in our world cup odyssey um and we're looking at the seven wonders of poland we've had three, Dominic, and you're going to tell us now about the fourth. So, Tom, you will recall you were very sceptical. I thought cruelly sceptical about Cracus, who poisoned a dragon with a lamb. Yes. The founder of Cracus.
我的确怀疑他。现在，你会记得那条龙的名字，斯莫克·瓦韦尔斯基（Smok Wawelski）。是的。大家都会记得那条龙的名字，斯莫克·瓦韦尔斯基，对吧？克拉克说，他住在现在以他的名字命名的山下的洞穴里——也就是克拉科夫的瓦维尔山（Wavell Hill）。第四大奇观就是位于瓦维尔山顶的建筑群。所以我们回到了克拉科夫，这座山上有两座建筑非常值得一提。
I am sceptical of him. Now, you will recall the name of the dragon, Smok Wawelski. Yes. all recall the name of the dragon smock vavelsky yes and cracker said you know he lived in the cave under this hill that is now named after him vavel hill uh in krakow and the fourth wonder is the complex that's on the top of of vavel hill so we're back in krakow and there are two buildings on this on this hill that are worthy of note. So one of them, very much a building after your heart, is the cathedral. Ah, good.
其中一座非常符合你的心意，那就是大教堂。啊，太好了。
So it's a Gothic cathedral. The Polish kings used to be crowned here, and they would go on this procession through Krakow to get to the cathedral. And the route of the procession was known as the Royal Road. So you can still walk the Royal Road or whatever. Often Polish kings were buried in the cathedral. lots of other famous people are buried there you know the titanic figures of polish history so general sikorski who is the leader of the polish government in exile in the second world war in london he's buried there uh joseph pilsudski who beat the russians um in
这是一座哥特式大教堂。波兰国王以前在这里加冕，他们会穿过克拉科夫进行游行，最终到达大教堂。这条游行路线被称为“王室之路”（Royal Road）。所以你现在仍然可以走王室之路等等。波兰国王通常会被安葬在大教堂里。波兰历史上的许多其他名流也安葬在那里——例如在伦敦领导二战波兰流亡政府的西科尔斯基将军（General Sikorski）就安葬在那里；在 20 世纪 20 年代击败俄国人、作为独立波兰之父的约瑟夫·毕苏斯基（Josef Pilsudski）也安葬在那里。这里就是波兰的威斯敏斯特教堂。
the 1920s and is the sort of father of independent poland he's buried there it's it's the westminster abbey of it is the westminster abbey yeah the greatest polish poet adam mitskevich great romantic writer uh famous his poem pan tadeusz he is buried there but the most famous person tom a krakow boy former krakow student uh now he's not buried there. But the most famous person, Tom, a Krakow boy, former Krakow student. Now, he's not buried there, but he is associated with the building. A man called Karol Wojtyla. And you certainly will know who he is because he went on to become the Pope. Pope John Paul II.
这里就是威斯敏斯特教堂，是的。最伟大的波兰诗人亚当·密茨凯维奇（Adam Mickiewicz）——伟大的浪漫主义作家，以长诗《塔杜施先生》闻名——也安葬在那里。但最著名的人物，汤姆——一个克拉科夫男孩、前克拉科夫学生——现在他没有安葬在那里。但最著名的人物，汤姆，一个克拉科夫男孩，前克拉科夫学生，现在他没有安葬在那里，但他与这座建筑息息相关。这个人叫卡罗尔·沃伊蒂瓦（Karol Wojtyla）。你肯定知道他是谁，因为他后来成为了教皇，也就是教皇若望·保禄二世（Pope John Paul II）。
And his return to Poland in 1979 was a key moment in the foundation of solidarity, the trade union that helped to bring down communism. Is Lech Walesa buried there? He's not dead. Lech Walesa's still alive? Yeah, he's 79. Oh, bless him. I mean, he looked about 49 when he was leading Solidarity.
他在 1979 年对波兰的访问是“团结工会”（Solidarity）建立的关键时刻，这个工会帮助推翻了共产主义。莱赫·瓦文萨（Lech Walesa）被安葬在那里吗？他还没死呢。莱赫·瓦文萨还活着？对，他 79 岁了。哦，祝他健康。我的意思是，他领导“团结工会”的时候看起来大概 49 岁。
Yeah, he did. He looked like an ancient Gaul, didn't he? He looked like a man who worked in a Polish shipyard. Well, he did but he looked like an ancient ghoul didn't he had a he looked like a yeah like a man who worked in a polish shipyard yeah so i mean well he did well he did uh so he's not buried there but but maybe he will be i just think he will be um so the other building on the hill is called vavel castle and this has a slightly grimmer story um so it's a real hodgepodge it's not a particularly attractive building it's a hodgepodge. It's not a particularly attractive building. It's a hodgepodge of Gothic Renaissance and Baroque. It was always being looted by the Swedes
没错，他当时看起来像个古代高卢人，对吧？他看起来像个……他看起来像个在波兰造船厂工作的人。嗯，他确实……但他的确在造船厂工作过。所以他不在那儿安葬，但也许以后会的。我只是觉得他以后会被安葬在那里。所以，山上的另一座建筑叫做瓦维尔城堡，这个地方有一段稍微有些阴暗的故事。它真是一个大杂烩，它并不是一座特别吸引人的建筑。它是一个大杂烩。它并不是一座特别吸引人的建筑。它是哥特式、文艺复兴式和巴洛克式的大杂烩。它总是被瑞典人、普鲁士人等等掠夺。
and by the Prussians and so on. When Poland was partitioned, Krakow was Austrian, and the Austrians treated it with sort of neglect. So it was... It fell into disrepair. But after Poland became independent at the end of World War I,
当波兰被瓜分时，克拉科夫属于奥地利，奥地利人对它采取了一种忽视的态度。所以它……它年久失修。但在波兰于一战结束时获得独立后，
it became an unofficial residence of the Polish president, although the Polish president spent most of his time in Warsaw. When he came to Kraków, he would stay there. Then the Germans invade in 1939, and its most infamous resident is the guy who Hitler sends to run occupied Poland, known as the General Government, who is his personal lawyer, Hans Frank, I suppose, about the Nazis, because Hans Frank was not a brutal Philistine. He was an extremely civilized and educated man who played the piano, who decorated the castle with looted artworks, who summoned intellectuals and people to play chess with and all these kinds of things so he's got it's quite a troubling i mean he's a troubling figure anyway obviously but he's a he's a troubling figure because he is you know he's that that stereotype of a kind of
它成为了波兰总统的非官方官邸，尽管波兰总统大部分时间都在华沙度过。当他来到克拉科夫时，就会住在那里。然后德国人在 1939 年入侵，其最声名狼藉的住户是希特勒派来管理被占领波兰（被称为“总督府”辖区）的人，也就是希特勒的私人律师汉斯·弗兰克（Hans Frank）。我认为，关于纳粹，汉斯·弗兰克并不是一个野蛮的庸俗之辈。他是一个极度文明和受过良好教育的人，会弹钢琴，用掠夺来的艺术品装饰城堡，召集知识分子和各界人士来下棋等等。所以他是一个相当令人不安的人物——我的意思是，无论如何他都是一个令人不安的人物，但他之所以特别令人不安，是因为他正是那种……
yeah extremely elegantly you know his wife yeah you know she she styles herself as the queen of poland the thing is um polish people are now under his rule banned from visiting their own castle they can only visit if they're cleaners now the only poles allowed inside and you mentioned roman polanski in the first half of this episode polanski's mother was a cleaner and she was allowed, therefore, to visit the castle when Hans Frank was there. And at the end of the war, a bit like with Zamosh, when the Nazis are clearly losing, they give instructions for the castle to be wired with dynamite and blown up. But for reasons that to this day I think are slightly unclear,
那种极其优雅的刻板印象……你知道的，他的妻子……你知道的，她自命为波兰女王。问题是，在汉斯·弗兰克的统治下，波兰人现在被禁止参观他们自己的城堡。如果他们是清洁工，他们才能参观——这是现在唯一允许进入城堡的波兰人。你在本集前半部分提到了罗曼·波兰斯基，波兰斯基的母亲就是一名清洁工，因此当汉斯·弗兰克在那里时，她被允许进入城堡。在战争结束时，就像扎莫希奇的情况一样，当纳粹明显战败时，他们下达了指令，要在城堡里布满炸药并将其炸毁。但出于某种原因，直到今天我认为仍有些不甚明了，
they didn't detonate it, so the castle was not in fact destroyed. And just a question about the Soviets when they arrive. Yeah. They don't kind of see these as… Bourgeois. Well, emblems of Polish identity as well as emblems of feudal reaction. I suspect the Soviets do see that. But what's interesting is that under the Polish communist regime
他们没有引爆它，所以城堡实际上并没有被摧毁。顺便问一下，苏维埃人抵达时是什么情况？是的。他们难道不把这些视为……资产阶级产物吗？嗯，既是波兰认同的象征，也是封建反动势力的象征。我猜苏维埃人确实是这么看的。但有趣的是，在二战结束后的波兰共产主义政权下，
at the end of World War II, there's a huge effort that goes into conservation. So particularly in Warsaw, Warsaw is rebuilt under the communists in this kind of painstaking style. You go to Warsaw, there's sort of the old town square and stuff. I mean, all that is, as it were, inverted commas,
投入了大量精力进行文物保护。特别是华沙，华沙在共产主义统治下以这种煞费苦心的风格进行了重建。你去华沙，那里有老城广场之类的东西。我的意思是，所有这些都是——加了引号的——
fake rebuilt at the end of world war two. So no, I think the Polish, the Polish communist authorities have a, they're proud of the country's history. Yes. Well, well with,
在二战结束后虚假重建的。所以不，我认为波兰的共产主义当局有一种……他们为国家的历史感到自豪。是的。好吧，在某种程度上，
to a degree, I mean, it'd be interesting to, if we have Polish listeners who know more about this stuff than frankly, than I do, um, to explain the kind of the kind of very ambiguous relationship they have with their own past. So that's number four, anyway.
如果我们的波兰听众比我——坦白说——更了解这些事情，能来解释一下他们与自身历史那种非常暧昧的关系，那将是非常有趣的。所以无论如何，这就是第四个奇观。
We've got three to go, Tom. Okay. And the top three, I have to say, they are absolutely fantastic-sounding places, none of which I have been to. So you've been to the other four, have you? If you believe I've been to the other four, that uh if you believe i've been to the other four that's a tribute to my podcasting because i haven't no it was just the way you frame that yes i know what i find that deliberately to try and suggest above a degree of expertise you're an old poland hand exactly well i know my
我们还有三个，汤姆。好的。而且前三名，我必须说，听起来绝对是令人向往的绝佳去处，而这其中每一个我都还没去过。所以你把前四个都去过了吗？如果你相信我都去过了，那这真是对我的播客主持功力的褒奖，因为我其实都没去过。不，我只是根据你的语气……是的，我知道我刚才故意那样说，是为了展现出一定程度的专业度，让你听起来像个“老波兰通”。完全正确，不过我很清楚……
i know my linguistic ability well he, you've been to Belarus. I have been to Belarus. And in fact, I've been to Warsaw, but I haven't been to... I've never been anywhere in Poland outside Warsaw. Okay, so number three, I know everybody likes a proper castle, and this is a proper castle. This is, in fact, the largest castle in the world. Is it?
我知道我的语言能力很好，嘿，你去过白俄罗斯。我去过白俄罗斯。事实上，我去过华沙，但我没有去过……除了华沙，我从来没去过波兰的其他任何地方。好吧，第三点，我知道每个人都喜欢真正的城堡，而这就是一座真正的城堡。事实上，这是世界上最大城堡。是吗？
It's Malbork Castle. Wow. The great castle of the Teutonic knights the nazis must have loved them they oh well i'll tell you and not just the nazis as we will discover so the teutonic knights as you will probably note on were founded in acre in 1191 by german merchants and then they get involved in all these kind of prussian crusades and baltic crusades a few decades later so in the early what are we the early um 13th century when the teutonic knights had conquered what's called old prussia so basically east prussia these days it's partly poland partly the russian enclave of cliningrad they wanted to cement their control of the area over the baltic tribes and of course they do what people do in the Middle Ages. They build this massive castle.
这是马尔堡城堡。哇。条顿骑士团的大城堡，纳粹一定很喜欢他们，哦，好吧，我来告诉你，不仅仅是纳粹，正如我们将会发现的那样。条顿骑士团，正如你可能会注意到的那样，于1191年由德国商人在阿克里创立，几十年后，他们卷入了各种普鲁士十字军东征和波罗的海十字军东征。所以在大约，我们现在在什么时候？大约13世纪早期，当条顿骑士团征服了所谓的“老普鲁士”——基本上就是现在的东普鲁士，一部分属于波兰，一部分属于俄罗斯的加里宁格勒飞地——他们想要巩固对该地区波罗的海部落的控制，当然，他们做了中世纪人们会做的事。他们建造了这座巨大的城堡。
And it clearly took them, there's no records left of the castle's building, but we know that it must have taken them decades. It's on the bank of the river Nogat, and they called it Marienburg after their patron saint, the Virgin Mary. Eventually, it becomes the administrative center of the Teutonic Knights' kind of land of East Prussia. It gives them control of the amber trade on the river. So obviously, Baltic amber is incredibly lucrative. And it acquires this sort of romantic place in the German-speaking world's imagination as the castle of these sort of terrifyingly grim crusaders who have subdued the tribes of the sort of wild, swampy, forested northeast. But the Teutonic state is defeated, cruciallycially at the battle of grunwald in 1410
很明显，他们花了——没有留下这座城堡建造的任何记录，但我们知道它一定花了他们几十年的时间。它坐落在诺加特河畔，他们以他们的守护神圣母玛利亚的名字将其命名为马林堡。最终，它成为了条顿骑士团在东普鲁士领地的行政中心。这使他们控制了河上的琥珀贸易。所以很明显，波罗的海琥珀极其赚钱。它在德语世界的想象中获得了一种浪漫的地位，被视为那些令人毛骨悚然、冷酷无情的十字军的城堡，他们征服了东北部野生、沼泽密布、森林茂密的部落。但是条顿国战败了，最关键的是在1410年的格伦瓦尔德战役中。
so that's the the eisenstein in the eisenstein film is it no that's that's that's by alexander nevsky when they're attacking russia but they're then beaten by the poles by the poles and lithuanians and that was the battle of late pipus but this is the battle of grunwaldwald so they're beaten there in 1410 and after that point the Teutonic state is never really the same again so ultimately Marienburg castle is taken over by the um by the Poles and it goes through a time when Poland is partitioned when it's Prussian again and then it basically becomes Polish at the end of World War II and is polish obviously to this day and the remarkable thing about it so i've described it as a castle but actually it doesn't really give a true sense because of course the remarkable thing about it is that it is brick it is all brick not stone so it's kind of red brick a red brick castle
所以那是爱森斯坦，在爱森斯坦的电影里，对吧？不，那是，那是亚历山大·涅夫斯基的电影，当时他们在进攻俄罗斯。但他们随后被波兰人击败了——被波兰人和立陶宛人击败，那是楚德湖战役。但这是格伦瓦尔德战役，所以他们在1410年在那里的战败，在那之后，条顿国就再也不是以前的样子了。最终，马林堡城堡被波兰人接管，它经历了波兰被瓜分、再次属于普鲁士的时期，然后它在二战结束时基本上变成了波兰的领土，显然直到今天它依然属于波兰。关于它，最引人注目的一点是——我把它描述为一座城堡，但实际上这并不能真正传达出它的真实面貌，因为当然，它最引人注目的是它是用砖建造的，全部是用砖，而不是石头，所以它有点像红砖，是一座红砖城堡。
it's one of the world's largest brick buildings of any kind. So it has churches, it has chapels, it has a colossal refectory, it has all this kind of stuff. And it looks, therefore, completely unlike a castle you'd find in, you know, North Wales or the Long Dock or the other great kind of castle. Do you know, I have seen it. I mean, not in person, but I know about it. Yeah.
它是世界上任何种类的最大砖砌建筑之一。所以它有教堂，有小礼堂，有一个巨大的食堂，有所有这些各种各样的东西。因此，它看起来完全不像你在北威尔士或朗多克或其他伟大的城堡里能找到的任何城堡。你知道吗，我是见过的。我的意思是，不是亲眼所见，但我知道它。是的。
Are you aficionado of medieval combat, which is a sport that was originally developed by the Russians? You've told me about this before. And then they practiced it. It was too brutal. So then they reconfigured it and expelled the Russians. Anyway, they have an annual championship. And they do it there.
你是中世纪格斗的爱好者吗？这项运动最初是由俄罗斯人开发的。你以前跟我说过这个。然后他们练习了它。它太残酷了。所以他们重新配置了它，并把俄罗斯人开除了。不管怎样，他们有一个年度锦标赛。他们在那里举行。
One of the annual championships was at Marburg. Well, you see, you should definitely visit it tom you'd love it because do you know who also you'd be following in the footsteps of a great friend of the rest is history do you want to guess who it is uh who would enjoy a teutonic knight's castle in occupied you know poland i don't know it's kaiser wilhelm the second oh is it yeah is it and you know what he did he wore the right shoes to this i guess he well he he did because he dressed up as a teutonic monk that's definitely wearing the right costume i would not recommend that you do what he did next which is he gave a virulently violently anti-polish speech no i wouldn't i think that would be very high risk but you could dine i've i've dug out for you the um
其中一届年度锦标赛就在马尔堡举行。你看，你绝对应该去参观一下，汤姆，你会喜欢的，因为你知道你还将追随《历史的剩余》一位伟大朋友的脚步吗？你想猜猜是谁吗？呃，谁会喜欢在被占领的波兰的一座条顿骑士团城堡呢？我不知道。是威廉二世皇帝吗？哦，是吗？是的，是吗？你知道他做了什么吗？我猜他穿了正确的鞋子……嗯，他确实这么做了，因为他把自己打扮成了一个条顿修士。这绝对是穿对了服装。我不建议你做他接下来做的事，那就是发表了一场充满狂热和暴力反波兰情绪的演讲。不，我不会，我想那会有极高的风险。不过你可以用餐，我为你挖出了……
the menu for what the kaiser ate when he went to uh malbork castle was it bison he's kicked off with something called kaiser soup i don't know what that is but i think a soup i was about to say you should definitely have something named after yourself we should find we should find that out shouldn't we yeah we could have a kind of restless history restaurant well i was reality of the day kaiser soup the kaiser started with something named after himself and you should do that but then i looked at the rest of the menu this will not be an issue for you because the very next dish was called turbot fish in holland style brilliant so you're laughing he had veal he had ham what in this menu he had strasburger pudding i don't know what that is he had goose he had
皇帝去马尔堡城堡时吃的东西的菜单。是野牛肉吗？他以一种叫皇帝汤的东西开场，我不知道那是什么，但我想是一道汤。我正要说，你应该绝对吃一份以你自己名字命名的东西。我们应该找找，我们应该找出来，对吧？是的，我们可以开一家类似“历史的剩余”餐厅。好吧，当天的现实是“皇帝汤”，皇帝以一个以自己名字命名的东西开始，你也应该这样做。但后来我看了看菜单的其余部分，这对你来说不是问题，因为紧接着的一道菜叫做“荷兰风味大比目鱼”。太棒了！所以你在笑，他吃了小牛肉，他吃了火腿，在这个菜单里，他吃了斯特拉斯堡布丁，我不知道那是什么，他吃了鹅，他吃了……
asparagus strawberries and cream cheese sticks and desserts and what was he after dinner entertainment don't know what's that was there any uh any uh any dancing yeah german generals dressed as Any ballet dancing. Yeah. German generals dressed as ballerinas who died unexpectedly. Sorry, this is a reference to our podcast about the world's worst parties, which will be lost on some listeners. Anyway, that's your holiday absolutely sorted, isn't it? Yes, it is. You're laughing. It is.
芦笋、草莓、奶油奶酪条和甜点。晚饭后的娱乐活动是什么？不知道，那是什么？有什么，有什么，有什么舞蹈吗？是的，德国将军们打扮成……有什么芭蕾舞表演吗？是的，德国将军们打扮成意想不到地死去的芭蕾舞演员。抱歉，这是对我们关于世界上最糟糕派对的播客的引用，有些听众可能听不懂。不管怎样，你的假期绝对安排好了，不是吗？是的，确实如此。你在笑。确实如此。
So we've got two to go. Okay. Number two is another beautiful city with a scientific connection tom just for you this is where copernicus comes in yes this is a town of toronia so this is uh in central poland it's midway between warsaw and gdansk i won't go give you a whole run through through its early history because that's kind of very similar to the others is Is there a dragon? There's no dragon. There's an awful lot of cloth hall-type behavior. So guilds, Hanseatic leagues. Hanseatic league carrying on.
所以我们还有两个要去。好的。第二座是另一座与科学有渊源的美丽城市，汤姆，专为你准备的，哥白尼就是在这里登场的。是的，这是托伦镇，所以这是……在波兰中部，位于华沙和格但斯克之间。我不打算给你完整介绍它的早期历史，因为那与其他地方非常相似。有龙吗？没有龙。这里有大量布匹大厅式的行为。所以有行会，汉萨同盟。汉萨同盟一直在延续。
Artisans, you know, all this sort of stuff. Because it's located on the River Vistula. Which always slightly sounds like a medical condition, I think. It does. It does, yeah. Nice. Got a terrible viscera. So it's on a ford in the Vistula, so it's a perfect trading center.
工匠，你知道，所有这些类似的东西。因为它是坐落在维斯瓦河畔。这听起来总是有点像某种内科疾病，我觉得。确实。确实，是的。很好。得了可怕的内脏病。所以它位于维斯瓦河的一个浅滩上，因此它是绝佳的贸易中心。
It becomes a big Protestant center. It's very multicultural. But there are three things that mark it out. First of all, like some of these other places, it is not damaged in the Second World War. So it's medieval architecture. Just luck. It had awful massacres, actually, in World War ii and it was a big center for the polish resistance but through
它成为了一个重大的新教中心。这里非常多元文化。但有三件事让它脱颖而出。首先，和其中一些其他地方一样，它在第二次世界大战中没有受到破坏。所以它是中世纪的建筑。全凭运气。实际上，它在二战中遭受了可怕的大屠杀，并且它是波兰抵抗运动的一个重要中心，但通过……
luck it wasn't particularly damaged um it has i read the best collection of gothic brick buildings in europe so it has a cathedral like medieval brick buildings, Poland is clearly the place to go. Not only is Poland the place, but this has probably been the best podcast of your life. Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely. Your hour has come. Yeah. Yes.
运气，它没有受到特别的破坏。嗯，我读到过它是欧洲哥特式砖砌建筑最好的收藏地，所以它拥有像中世纪砖砌建筑一样的教堂。波兰显然是个值得一去的地方。不仅波兰是个好地方，这可能还是你一生中最棒的一集播客。是的，绝对的。绝对的。你的高光时刻到了。Yeah.是的。
So there's guild halls, there's merchant's houses. Now, there's one house in particular that you would want to visit, Tom. It's on 17 Copernica street i definitely would it's a sort of again a brick building gothic brick sort of narrow terrace soaring so the kind of building absolutely that you would see if you went to bruges or ghent or somewhere um now in the 15th century this belonged to a man called mikawai who came from a silesian family he was a copper trader and he married a local counselor's daughter called barbara and they had barbara yes that is that a polish name maybe clearly it is it's kind of um wow well actually national intensity
所以这里有行会大厅，有商人的房屋。现在，有一栋房子是你特别想去参观的，汤姆。它在哥白尼街17号。我绝对想去。它有点像，同样是一栋砖砌建筑，哥特式砖墙，有点像狭窄的联排别墅，高耸入云，绝对是你在布鲁日、根特或其他什么地方会看到的那种建筑。现在，在15世纪，这属于一个名叫米科瓦伊（Mikołaj）的人，他来自一个西里西亚家庭。他是一名铜商，他娶了一位当地议员的女儿，名叫芭芭拉，他们生下了……芭芭拉，是的，这是一个波兰名字吗？也许吧，显然是的。它有点像……哇。好吧，实际上，民族的密集度……
is slightly muddy and ambiguous experience we should go go on to yeah exactly is it german or polish um because their son we call their son nicholas copernicus um he was born in 1473 and he is a classic polish renaissance figure he's a doctorate in law he's a mathematician he's a cathedral canon he's obsessed obviously with astronomy which is why we know about him. But what is he? Is he, in a vertical, Polish? Well, he spoke Latin, Greek, Italian, and Polish, but probably his native language was German.
是一个有点模糊和模棱两可的体验。我们应该继续去……对，没错。它是德国的还是波兰的？因为他们的儿子——我们称他们的儿子为尼古拉·哥白尼——他出生于1473年，他是典型的波兰文艺复兴人物。他拥有法律博士学位，他是数学家，他是教堂教士，他显然痴迷于天文学，这就是为什么我们知道他。但他究竟是什么？从根本上说，他是波兰人吗？嗯，他说拉丁语、希腊语、意大利语和波兰语，但可能他的母语是德语。
But, of course, the Poles claim him. I mean, he studied in Padua, of course. Where else? He spent time in Rome. He's most famous for his thing about revolutions of the heavenly spheres. And, of course, Poland makes a huge deal about Copernicus, as you would. But the Germans, historically, have always tried to claim Copernicus as German. So I looked up what Norman Davis, the great historian of Poland, said.
但是，当然，波兰人声称他是波兰人。我的意思是，他曾在帕多瓦学习，当然。还能在哪里？他在罗马待过。他最著名的是关于天体运行论的著作。当然，波兰对哥白尼大加宣传，这是理所当然的。但历史上，德国人一直试图宣称哥白尼是德国人。所以我查阅了波兰伟大历史学家诺曼·戴维斯（Norman Davis）的说法。
He said, taking everything into consideration, there is good reason to regard Copernicus both as a German and as a pole. And yet in the sense that modern nationalists understand it, he was of course, neither. So that's the very norm Davis. It is. It is.
他说，综合考虑所有因素，有充分的理由把哥白尼既看作德国人，又看作波兰人。然而，在现代民族主义者所理解的意义上，他当然两者都不是。这就是诺曼·戴维斯的观点。确实如此。确实如此。
Having his cake, eating it, Tom, or is he having his gingerbread and eating it because torunia is also the world's great center of gingerbread making that is top podcasting thank you seamless that was kind of like a ballerina like a german general in a tutu doing a perfect pirouette absolutely Absolutely masterly. So Torunia is perfectly placed for gingerbread. They've got everything they need. They've got all the wheat and all
既想鱼与熊掌兼得吗，汤姆？还是说他想吃姜饼并且还要把它吃掉？因为托伦也是世界姜饼制作的伟大中心。这是顶级的播客制作，谢谢你，天衣无缝。那有点像芭蕾舞演员，就像一个穿着芭蕾裙的德国将军在做完美的旋转，绝对的。绝对大师级。所以托伦是制作姜饼的绝佳地点。他们拥有他们需要的一切。他们拥有所有的麦子和所有……
that stuff. They've got water. They've also got the spices because of its position on the trade routes. So spices are coming through from the Black Sea and so on or they're coming to Gdansk. So the first mention of Torunia gingerbread comes from 1380
那些东西。他们有水。由于它在贸易路线上的位置，他们还有香料。所以香料来自黑海等地，或者它们正运往格但斯克。因此，关于托伦姜饼的首次记载可以追溯到1380年。
the cistercians produced loads of gingerbread under the prussians there was a factory that was exporting gingerbread so this is obviously in the i say under the prussians we're talking about in the 19th century they were exporting gingerbread from this town to China, would you believe? I know I sound like Liz Truss talking about pork markets. Exactly. I'm talking about gingerbread markets. And if you go there, Tom, you can buy gingerbread moulded in the shape of Pope John Paul II. Wow.
熙笃会士在普鲁士人统治下生产了大量的姜饼，曾有一家工厂出口姜饼——所以这显然是在我说在普鲁士人统治下，我们说的是在19世纪，他们把姜饼从这个小镇出口到中国，你信吗？我知道我听起来像伊丽莎白·特拉斯在谈论猪肉市场。没错。我在谈论姜饼市场。如果你去那里，汤姆，你可以买到做成教皇若望·保禄二世形状的姜饼。哇。
But surely in Copernicus as well, or maybe a model of the Copernican universe? Undoubtedly. Undoubtedly undoubtedly i've got to go so i've got one wonder left the top wonder now you said you had a wonder of your own that you wanted to see and i wonder if it well i wonder if it's going to be the same one which is the place you want to see well i don't know how to pronounce it what is it okay it's a forest it's not that okay can i? Okay, we'll come to... Tell me about your forest.
但当然也有哥白尼形状的，或者也许是哥白尼宇宙的模型？毫无疑问。毫无疑问，毫无疑问，我得去。所以我剩下一个奇观了，顶级奇观。现在你说过你有一个你想看的自己的奇观，我想知道它是否……我想知道它会不会是同一个，也就是你想看的地方。嗯，我不知道怎么发音，那是什么？好吧，那是一片森林。不是那个。好吧，我可以吗？好吧，我们来谈谈……跟我讲讲你的森林。
I hope that I have my pronunciation right. It's the B-O-A-S-I-A forest. The B-O-A-S-I-A forest. I freely admit... Bang goes that money from the Polish tourist board. But it's also in Belarus. So I thought that might be of interest to you. I know that might be of interest to you. And it's supposedly the only part of the primordial European forest that Caesar saw when he went to the Rhine.
希望我的发音是正确的。那是比亚沃维亚（Białowieża）森林。比亚沃维亚森林。我坦白承认……波兰旅游局的那笔赞助经费泡汤了。但它也在白俄罗斯。所以我想这可能会引起你的兴趣。我知道这可能会引起你的兴趣。据说这是凯撒去莱茵河时看到的原始欧洲森林中仅存的部分。
And it's all that there is left. That's absolutely right. And there's 800 of the European bison left that, again, were part of the primordial cattle stock that roamed it. And there's a brilliant chapter about it in one of shama's books i think it's landscape and memory uh and ever since i read that i've wanted to go so um that's not but that's not one of the wonders that's not it i guess because part of it is in belarus so it's in belarus that's where they proclaimed the end i think of the soviet union oh yeah right. On the Belarusian side.
而这就是仅存的一切。完全正确。还有800头欧洲野牛，它们也是漫游在那里的原始牛群的一部分。西玛（Shama）的一本书里有一章非常精彩，我想那是《风景与记忆》（Landscape and Memory）。自从我读了那本书以来，我就一直想去，所以……那不是，但那不是奇观之一，那不是。我想因为它的一部分在白俄罗斯，所以它在白俄罗斯，那是他们宣布苏联解散的地方，我想。哦，是的，没错。在白俄罗斯一侧。
No, this is a salt mine. A salt mine? Are you not familiar with a Vyolitska salt mine? No. You would love it. Okay, convince me. So Vyolitska is just outside Krakow. The mine goes 1,000 feet deep.
不，这是一个盐矿。盐矿？你对维利奇卡（Wieliczka）盐矿不熟悉吗？不。你会喜欢的。好吧，说服我。所以维利奇卡就在克拉科夫郊外。这个矿深达1000英尺。
The chambers and corridors of the mine, Tom, extend for 178 miles. Okay, that is a wonder. Embers and corridors of the mine, Tom, extend for 178 miles. Okay. That is a wonder. That really is a wonder. Yeah. God. So they discovered salt.
汤姆，这个矿的密室和走廊延伸了178英里。好吧，那真是一个奇观。矿井的密室和走廊，汤姆，延伸了178英里。好吧。那真的是一个奇观。那真的真的是一个奇观。是的。天哪。所以他们发现了盐。
They started in the sort of 11th, well, before that, actually, even in the Neolithic times, they found salt, and they were sort of getting salt from springs, boiling it, and so on. In the 11th and 12th centuries, they were sort of getting salt from springs boiling it and so on in the 11th and 12th centuries they were digging wells in the 13th century they started to find lumps of rock salt and then it occurred to them that they could start mining uh king casimir the great he really encouraged this um so that in the mid 14th century, about a third of the Polish Royal treasury's income was coming from this salt, this salt mine.
他们在大约11世纪，嗯，更早之前，实际上，甚至在新石器时代，他们就发现了盐，他们从泉水中获取盐，将其煮沸等等。在11世纪和12世纪，他们从泉水中获取盐，将其煮沸等等。在13世纪，他们开始发现岩盐块，然后他们想到他们可以开始采矿。卡齐米日大王（King Casimir the Great）大力鼓励这样做，因此在14世纪中期，波兰王室国库收入的大约三分之一都来自这种盐，这种盐矿。
Unbelievably, uh, the end of the middle ages, they had four mining shafts. They're producing about 8,000 tons of salt. God, I've, I've just looked it up.
难以置信的是，到中世纪末，他们有四个采矿井。他们生产大约8000吨盐。天哪，我刚刚查了一下。
They've got a chapel. Yes. The first, so God, it looks amazing. It looks like, it looks like something from the rings of power. It is. It's bloody Casa so. God, it looks amazing. It looks like something from the Rings of Power. It is.
他们有一个小教堂。是的。第一座，所以天哪，它看起来太棒了。它看起来像，它看起来像《力量之戒》里的东西。是的。这简直就是莫瑞亚矿坑。天哪，它看起来太棒了。它看起来像《力量之戒》里的东西。是的。
It's bloody Casa Doom. Yes, it is. Yes, the Mines of Moria. So tourists start going in the early modern period. Do you know, Tom, the name of the first tourist to visit the Wieliczka salt mine? Dominic Schlandbruch. No, it was Nicholas Copernicus. Was it? Wow. The threads you were weaving into a beautiful tapestry he visited in 1493 and there's a massive figure of copernicus set up inside the
这简直就是莫瑞亚矿坑。是的，它是。是的，莫瑞亚矿坑。所以游客在近代早期开始前往。你知道吗，汤姆，访问维利奇卡盐矿的第一位游客的名字？多米尼克·什兰布鲁赫（Dominic Schlandbruch）。不，那是尼古拉·哥白尼。是吗？哇。你把这些线索编织成了一幅美丽的织锦。他在1493年访问过这里，里面竖立着一座巨大的哥白尼雕像……
salt mine and you could admire it when you go so it's so large that people start creating maps of it um so there are beautifully illustrated maps of it from the early 17th century. By the mid-17th century, the salt mine is on three different levels. Tourists are going every year. It's mentioned by European travelers. They have to get personal permission from the king.
盐矿里，当你去的时候你可以去瞻仰它。它是如此之大，以至于人们开始绘制它的地图，所以那里有来自17世纪早期的精美插图地图。到17世纪中期，这个盐矿已经分为三个不同的层级。游客每年都来。它被欧洲旅行者提及。他们必须获得国王的个人许可。
As I said, the Krakow area is taken over by the Austrians. The Austrians are very keen on this. They build a railway line underneath through these sort of tunnels of salt. And is that railway line, is it still going? I believe it's still there. Horse-drawn railway. But the Austrians are very keen on attracting tourists.
正如我所说，克拉科夫地区被奥地利人接管了。奥地利人对这个非常热衷。他们在这些盐洞下面修建了一条铁路线。那条铁路线现在还在运行吗？我相信它还在。马车铁路。但奥地利人非常热衷于吸引游客。
They think this will, and they were right because they arrange all kinds of things. so you go in from 1868 onwards you can go on a horse-drawn railway through the mine uh you can do what they call the devil's drop which is the miners descent into the mine on a rope sort of bungee jump into the mine you can go on boat rides inside the mine on a lake of salt wow and there's also there's a there's a miners orchestra that will play for you while you're touring the mine and they'll also do fireworks unbelievably i'm not sure i'd want not well i'm sure it's safe but yeah there's always the first time isn't there so it became incredibly incredibly popular and under independent poland at the end of the first world war becomes a real symbol of national
他们认为这会，他们的确猜对了，因为他们安排了各种各样的活动。所以从1868年开始，你可以乘坐马拉铁路穿过矿井；你可以做他们所说的“魔鬼坠落”，也就是矿工用一根绳子下到矿井里，有点像蹦极跳进矿井；你可以在矿井内的一个盐湖上乘船游玩。哇。还有一个矿工乐队会在你参观矿井时为你演奏，他们还会不可思议地燃放烟花。我不确定我是否想——嗯，我相信它是安全的，但凡事都有第一次，不是吗？所以它变得非常非常受欢迎。在第一次世界大战结束后的独立波兰，它成为了国家认同的一个真正的象征。
identity um so more than 100 000 people would visit every year they would organize all kinds of conventions political rallies things like that inside the mine it's slightly declined under communism they're no longer really producing. Salt production kind of reaches a peak in the 1970s and then declines, but tourism becomes more and more important. Basically, salt production ended in 1996, and it's now purely all about tourism. So the Statue of Copernicus, made of salt, of course. And this was made when? So the Statue of Copernicus was made in of course and this was made when so the statue
因此，每年有超过10万名游客参观。他们会在矿井内部组织各种大会、政治集会之类的事情。在共产主义时期，它稍微有些衰落，他们不再真正生产盐了。盐产量在20世纪70年代左右达到顶峰，然后下降，但旅游业变得越来越重要。基本上，盐生产在1996年结束了，现在它完全纯粹是为了旅游业。所以哥白尼雕像，当然是用盐做的。这是什么时候制作的？所以哥白尼雕像是用……当然，这是什么时候制作的？所以哥白尼雕像……
copernicus was made in the 20th century it's the 500th anniversary of his birth what a wonderful tribute yeah it's a great point of pride to the miners to make statues of people they approve of the most famous statue there is the statue of saint kinga i know you like saint tom but are you familiar with the story of saint kinga no so she was a hungarian princess and she had an arranged marriage with the prince of krakow who was called boaswaf the chaste that's that's the kind of bridegroom that you want isn't it yeah it bodes well itodes well. Which is that Henry VIII. Yeah. I don't know. So she, as a dowry,
是在20世纪制作的，那是他诞辰500周年。多么美妙的致敬啊。是的，对于矿工们来说，制作他们最赞赏的人的雕像是一个巨大的骄傲。那里最著名的雕像圣金加（Saint Kinga）的雕像。我知道你喜欢圣徒，汤姆，但你熟悉圣金加的故事吗？不。所以她是一位匈牙利公主，她与克拉科夫王子订了娃娃亲，这位王子名叫“虔诚者博莱斯瓦夫”（Bolesław the Chaste）。那是你想要的新郎类型，对吧？是的，这预示着好兆头，预示着好兆头。那就是亨利八世。是的。我不知道。所以作为嫁妆，
she asks her father, the King of Hungary, I mean, this is a slightly implausible story, for a lump of salt. He gives her this lump of salt. And she does a very strange thing. Before she leaves Hungary, she throws her engagement ring from the Polish prince into the shaft of the salt mine
她向她的父亲匈牙利国王请求——我的意思是，这是一个有点不太可能的故事——要了一块盐。他给了她这块盐。她做了一件非常奇怪的事情。在她离开匈牙利之前，她把波兰王子送给她的订婚戒指扔进了一个盐矿的竖井里，
that she got this lump of salt from. Then she goes off to Poland, to Krakow, and she says to the miners when she arrives, dig a huge pit until you come to a rock. They dig this pit. They find the ring. They come to the rock. They find a massive lump of salt
她就是从那个盐矿得到这块盐的。然后她动身前往波兰克拉科夫，她到达后对矿工们说：“去挖一个巨大的深坑，直到你们挖到一块岩石。”他们挖了这个坑。他们找到了戒指。他们挖到了岩石。他们发现了一块巨大的盐块，
presumably the same lump of salt that she had been given as the dowry they split it in two do you know what they find inside the ring
据推测，这就是作为嫁妆送给她的那块盐。他们把它劈成两半。你知道他们在里面发现了什么吗？
the ring that's magic so from that day on she became the patron saint of salt miners in Krakow I mean I don't think
那枚戒指，太神奇了。所以从那一天起，她成为了克拉科夫盐矿工的守护神。我的意思是，我不认为
that's really saintly behavior just miraculous yeah so her the miners built her a chapel made of salt inside the salt mine at the turn of the 20th century um so it's 100 meters beneath the earth the floor is made of salt there are murals of biblical scenes all made of salt chandeliers all of this stuff now the thing is this is how i want to end this podcast you can book that chapel now tom for 400 people and have meetings of your own there and i think this would be the most brilliant location for a meeting of the members of the rest is history club yeah it would yes it really would but i think what it depends on i want to see i will not arrange that meeting and i don't want goldhanger productions to arrange that
那真的是圣徒的行为，只是个奇迹。是的。所以矿工们在20世纪之交在盐矿内部为她建造了一座用盐做的小教堂。所以它位于地下100米处，地板是用盐做的，墙上画着圣经场景的壁画，全部是用盐做的，还有吊灯，所有这些东西。现在，问题是——这就是我想结束这个播客的方式——汤姆，你现在可以为400人预订那个小教堂，并在那里举办你自己的会议。我认为这将是“历史的剩余”俱乐部成员聚会的绝妙地点。是的，确实如此，真的如此。但我认为这取决于——我想看到——我不会安排那个会议，我也不想让金亨格制作公司（Goldhanger Productions）安排那个
meeting unless they see a rush of new applications to join the rest is history club on the back of this podcast so this is an incentive real incentive for listeners. If you want to have your meeting in the bowels of an incredibly safe salt mine where they've had fireworks. What could possibly go wrong? Yeah. Before Tom Holland takes you on a canal trip at 45 degrees. Yeah. Well, Dominic, that was brilliant.
会议，除非他们看到在这个播客播出后，加入“历史的剩余”俱乐部的申请数量激增。所以这对听众来说是一个真正的激励。如果你想在一个极其安全的、曾经放过烟花的盐矿深处举行你的会议——能出什么岔子呢？是的。在汤姆·霍兰带你去进行一次45度角的运河之旅之前。是的。好吧，多米尼克，太精彩了。
I didn't really know anything about any of those. And I absolutely want to go and see them all. So Poland, here I come. I think we should do Rest Is History. We should do location reports. We should. Yes, we should. That'd be great.
我真的对其中任何一个都不太了解。我绝对想去看看它们全部。所以波兰，我来啦。我想我们应该做《历史的剩余》。我们应该做实地报道。我们应该这样做。是的，我们应该。那太棒了。
Kind of like Michael Palin. Yeah, exactly. Perfect. All right. Well, thank you all for listening I won't say goodbye in Polish because my Polish frankly
有点像迈克尔·帕林（Michael Palin）。是的，完全正确。好的。好吧，谢谢大家收听。我不会用波兰语说再见，因为坦率地说我的波兰语
is non-existent but you'll just have to imagine it for yourselves and on that bombshell goodbye bye-bye thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
等于零，但你们只能自己想象了。伴随着这个重磅炸弹，再见，拜拜。感谢收听《历史的剩余》。想要获取独家单集、抢先收听、无广告收听
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment It's your weekly fix of entertainment news
以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的剩余》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻的固定节目，
reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works We have just launched
包括评论、一抹演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了
our Members Club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、独家单集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。这集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。